we have a lot of viewers who were anti
social justice warrior but still pro
Bernie Sanders fiscal policy I think
we're at the point now where everybody
has to admit that okay maybe you weren't
in on the gag but Bernie is as bad as
they come he's not a guy who actually
believes what he says because you want a
contrast him with Hillary Clinton the
guy's a charlatan the guy is the social
justice warrior in chief in case you
were wondering
his latest well it's not a blunder this
is proactive this is a guy who
proactively constantly throws out
inflammatory hyperbole and his latest he
accused Republicans of pushing a health
care bill that is worse and will kill
more people than 911 let's go to the
tape if 23 million Americans would it be
thrown off the insurance they currently
have which is what the House bill would
do up to up to 28,000 Americans every
single year could die that is 9 times
more than the tragic losses we suffered
on 9/11 every single year 9 is more than
eight nine is more those who are
wondering and never sounds matters about
that but not one to ever shy away from
hyperbole he just keeps he just kept
going do one stop nine times more than
that of 9/11 it is nearly ten times that
of Pearl Harbor and of course a fraction
yet to be calculated but significant
amount of the Jews killed at Auschwitz
by the Nazi regime it is also estimated
to be two times more than those deceased
from the good Lords global flood which
forced Noack aboard animals two by two
of course Noah had an ark where is the
American people's Park why is there
still a debate in 2017 of whether or not
an ark there's a human right also what
Tang's are you a banana or a potato
plantains it's time for you to shoot or
get off the pot you know I'm actually
not entirely sure what a plantain is is
it even accurate okay his claim 28,000
people will die from healthcare throws
that out there to do as 911 inflammatory
comparison um no Bernie's estimates are
not accurate they're based on the CBO
projection and by the way the CBO
they've already had to revise their
numbers before this isn't the first time
so let me read this from you from
National Review but you can also find
this up at PolitiFact where they talk
about how this claim is not entirely
true their current baseline predicts
that the exchange enrollment will
skyrocket to 18 million by 2018 now
here's the thing there's no evidence
that this is going to happen if you look
at the exchange enrollment that'll be
significantly higher or or more robust
than current levels especially when you
look we've talked about this premiums
going up sometimes 32 percent year over
year seventeen percent was the average
there was something like thirty states
where it went up close to forty percent
so the CBO is working off of its March
2016 baseline and that's important
because the performance of the bill
relative to that Rosie it's never been
close to their projections just with
that alone they're off by seven million
and there's actually good reason to
believe that only five million people as
opposed to twenty eight billion people
might lose their coverage I think
everyone in this room has a friend or a
family member who's sick who needs help
who we help out who we either give money
to we provide rides for them or we help
them with their health care there's this
myth that only the left and Bernie
Sanders are compassionate because we're
talking about people now who will be
kicked off of their health care and so
can you believe the Republicans wanted
it well actually Republicans we do take
care of our own we do want to take care
of people who we know we're just have a
fundamental mistrust that Bernie Sanders
and mrs. bank fraud herself
Sanders is it Jane Sanders Jeanne jam
think it's Jane Sanders Jane Sanders
okay there's this myth that the left has
a monopoly on compassion this is what
Bernie Sanders says um we just don't
want you to take our money and give it
to people we don't know we don't want to
put it into a system that actually has
unfortunately forced more people to lose
their health care through not
being able to afford it through no
longer being able to afford the
skyrocketing premiums or deductibles we
never talk about them
that's the Forgotten man no that's the
Forgotten family your print your average
deductible is $12,000 $16,000 per family
you've been going up 32 percent year
every year we don't care about you
because by god we have to compare the
amount of people losing their health
care and the subsequent falls death rate
to people who were killed in 911 because
Bernie Sanders has an election to win
when he is 98 years old
Republicans give more to charity
volunteer more time and give more blood
statistically it's not even close
there's a great book written by Brooks
it's called who really cares this is not
some right-wing extremist when it comes
to your personal givings Republicans are
better tippers leaving a median tip of
20% we just covered that in the website
compare that with a Bernie Sanders tip
of 15 percent to the penny he breaks out
his iPhone calculator even if it's a
dollar fifty five cent coffee
he doesn't even follow the $2 per drink
oh you know what Bernie Sanders is he's
pre redemption Ebenezer Scrooge
Evan easer Scrooge was are there no
prisons are there no poor houses my
taxes go to fund that fund those
institutions if these poor would rather
die they'd better do it and decrease the
surplus population
after that guess what Scrooge no longer
relies on the government to do his
charity form he does it personally it's
about personal responsibility Bernie
Sanders as you see through his tips as
you see see through charitable giving
Donald with Bernie but Barack Obama the
Clintons Joe Biden I think he gave less
than one percent of his income to
charity hey are there no prisons is that
no welfare he absolves himself a
personal responsibility when you believe
that centralized government is the
ultimate form of charity you tend to be
a selfish dick here's something else can
we finally admit that Bernie Sanders is
not this gee golly he believes what he
says he is the ultimate social justice
warrior saying that Republicans will
kill more people than 9/11 this is a guy
who's directly catered to black lives
matter he's directly gone out there and
parroted the fall statistic of women
earning 74 cents on the dollar this is
the guy who compares political
opposition to authoritarians and
fascists I remember back when Jon
Stewart had his rally for sanity
remember that his
for Saturday this was this was John
Stewart about as far left as he got back
then the slogan was I disagree with you
but I'm pretty sure you're not Hitler
why because they were trying to
insinuate that Republicans compared
everyone to Hitler that Republicans
dealt in hyperbole and the reasonable
people were the Democrats Bernie Sanders
just said Donald Trump's health care
bill will kill more people than 911 but
I'm pretty sure he is Hitler hey if you
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if you're
not aware of it now there's no way
you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lata with credit.com
slash mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than $6 a month and you
get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand at smug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside